מחשוב קוונטי נכנס לעידן השימושיות
כלומר אנחנו יכולים להתחיל להשתמש במחשבים קוונטיים כדי לפתור
בעיות מהעולם האמיתי, כולל כאלה שקשות מאוד
למחשבים קלאסיים
נושא חוזר בעידן הנוכחי
הוא שבעיה נפתרת
לראשונה על מחשב קוונטי
ואז לאחר מכן אנשים מוצאים דרך לעשות את זה על מחשב קלאסי
מחשב - מחזור זה של מחשוב קלאסי
וקוונטי שדוחפים אחד את השני לקצות
שלהם כנראה ימשיך
עוד כמה שנים - יש קטגוריות של בעיות שבהן מחשוב
קוונטי יכול להיות בעל יתרון מוכח
על מחשוב קלאסי
בהינתן התקדמות בתחומים כמו
הפחתת שגיאות ומספר ה-qubit-ים הזמינים
יש גם תחומי יישום שלמים
שבהם מחשוב קוונטי
עשוי להיות שימושי בטווח הקרוב יחסית
אחד מהתחומים האלה הוא למידת מכונה קוונטית או QML
למידת מכונה קוונטית מתייחסת
ליישום המחשוב הקוונטי על כל סוג של למידת
מכונה - יש כמובן
סוגים רבים של למידת מכונה
שני סוגים שמעניינים במיוחד הם
למידה מונחית שבה אתה
מאמן אלגוריתם באמצעות מערך נתונים מתויג
ולמידה לא מונחית שבה
האלגוריתם עובד מדגימות לא מתויגות
ומנסה ללמוד על ההתפלגות
או הפונקציה שמייצרת אותה
אלגוריתם לא מונחה עשוי
למשל ללמוד איך לייצר דגימות חדשות
מאותה התפלגות או איך
לאשכל את הדגימות לקבוצות עם מאפיינים דומים
גם למידה מונחית וגם לא מונחית כוללות לעיתים קרובות
הטמעה של נתונים במרחבים בעלי מימד גבוה יותר
ומניפולציה של נתונים במרחבים בעלי מימד גבוה יותר
אמורה לגרום לנו לחשוב על מחשוב קוונטי
תנו לי להסביר - תדמיינו שאתם מנסים לפתור את הבעיה האם
לסווג נקודת נתונים מהמישור
כעיגול או כצלב בהינתן נתוני האימון המתויגים כאן
לפעמים אפשר להפריד נתונים בצורה ברורה עם קו
או מישור במימדים נמוכים
כפי שמוצג כאן, וסיווג נקודות הנתונים האלה לפי
אלו שמעל הקו
ואלו שמתחת לקו אמור להיות
פשוט - אבל תסתכלו על ההתפלגות הזאת
ברור שאין קו נראה לעין שמפריד בין נקודות הנתונים
אבל בשביל הנתונים האלה אנחנו יכולים לדמיין איזה
מיפוי משני מימדים לשלושה מימדים
כך שאחרי יישום המיפוי הנתונים שלנו נראים
ככה, ויש בבירור מישור שמפריד בין שתי
הקטגוריות שאותו אנחנו יכולים להשתמש
לסיווג - אם הטיפול הזה נראה קצת פשטני מדי
אתם צודקים - אנחנו לא יכולים פשוט לשים את נקודות הנתונים שאנחנו רוצים
יותר למעלה בלי הצדקה
חייב להיות מיפוי
מההתפלגות הדו-ממדית שמפריד ביעילות
את נקודות הנתונים שלנו כדי שנוכל
להשתמש במיפוי כדי לסווג נקודות נתונים חדשות
על זה נדבר יותר בשיעור שנותן סיכום
של למידת מכונה, אבל מספיק לומר
שאפשר להסתכל על הבעיה
כניסיון של מיפויים שונים לתוך המרחב הרב-ממדי הזה
כדי לראות אילו מיפויים נותנים את ההפרדה הכי טובה
של נקודות נתונים מקטגוריות שונות
המניפולציה הזאת של נתונים במימדים גבוהים
היא תחום אחד שבו מחשוב קוונטי
עשוי להיות בעל השפעה גדולה - כדי להבין למה
בואו נחזור להבדלים בין קלאסי
ומחשוב קוונטי - בדיוק
כמו שמחשבים קלאסיים משתמשים בביטים של מידע
מחשבים קוונטיים משתמשים ב-qubit-ים
אבל בשביל מספר נתון של ביטים, נגיד ארבעה
מחשב קלאסי יכול לקבל כל אחד מ-
שתיים בחזקת ארבע, כלומר שישה עשר מצבים אפשריים
מחשב קוונטי יכול גם הוא לגשת לשישה עשר מצבים אפשריים
אבל הוא יכול להתקיים בסופרפוזיציה של כל
ששת עשר המצבים בו-זמנית
ואפשר לבצע פעולות על כל הסופרפוזיציה הזאת
עבור ארבעה qubit-ים זה אולי לא נשמע
כזה עניין גדול, אבל תדמיינו מה אפשר לעשות עם
מחשב קוונטי בשתיים בחזקת עשרים, או
שתיים בחזקת מאה ועשרים ושבע
מצבים בו-זמנית - יש הרבה הבדלים נוספים
בין מחשוב קלאסי וקוונטי שיש להם
תפקיד בנושא הזה
למצבים קוונטיים יש אמפליטודות הסתברות מרוכבות
מניפולציות של מערכות קוונטיות מתבצעות עם
אופרטורים יוניטריים, ומחשבים קוונטיים כפופים לסוגים שונים
של רעש ממחשבים קלאסיים
ההבדלים האלה יעלו
לאורך כל עבודת למידת המכונה הקוונטית שלך בתחומים
כמו קידוד נתונים, מיפוי פיצ'רים וצמצום שגיאות
במקרים מסוימים ההבדלים האלה בין קלאסי
ומחשבים קוונטיים מאפשרים לנו לתכנן
אלגוריתמים חדשים לגמרי - עכשיו זה היה סקירה קצרה מאוד
של האיחוד של שני תחומים מסובכים מאוד
אבל בתקווה שני דברים ברורים
למידת מכונה פותרת לעיתים קרובות בעיות
על ידי מניפולציה של נתונים במימדים גבוהים מאוד
ושנית, מחשבים קוונטיים מתאימים היטב
למניפולציה של נתונים במימדים גבוהים
ועושים זאת בצורה שונה ממערכות קלאסיות
זה אמור לתת לך תחושה
למה למידת מכונה היא תחום מבטיח
ליישום של מחשוב קוונטי שימושי